it's thrifty week and i believe that
cooking delicious meals for your family
doesn't have to be complicated or
expensive this is very personal for me
and i'm very passionate about it because
as much as we love food here at this
show i'm very into the realities of
families that work hard and need to put
food on the table for an economical
price and quickly so for me i was
thinking about okay sometimes i like the
less is more approach in the kitchen the
how do i have a reality meal that's also
like really amazing um less ingredients
less money less time and i have a quick
and simple
um one that parents will like as well as
kids so i'm already dripping everywhere
so you want to take um the best part is
there's only three ingredients this
costs twelve dollars and it feeds four
people and it takes minutes so this to
me is a great reality dinner and it's my
version of tortellini embroider which is
really just a fancy name for tortellini
and broth
all right let's get started all you need
is three ingredients start with any
stock that is your personal favorite i
think it tastes best best with a chicken
but if you're vegetarian this actually
whole meal can be vegetarian but we're
going with chicken today so
it says you know on the package um i
think we went with a bhutoni for this
um
they say about seven minutes i like it a
little on the al dente side you'll put
in this amount and it's gonna like bulk
up and then all of a sudden you're gonna
have like kind of twice the amount so
don't be surprised by that
then once it's all finished
which this is still cooking i'm going to
go to this bowl here you want to take it
and you want to i like a little cracked
pepper and parmesan cheese i mean it's
really this simple
broth
pasta in wait a few minutes
ladle it into your bowl
and then if it's just for your kids
that's it simple tortellini and broth
but if you're an adult and you have a
doll palette like me
you need that amazing umami and you want
a great fresh parmesan cheese now this
is the most expensive item in the entire
meal the fresh block of parmesan and i
think it is worth
spending the money but you can also i do
love me that skinny long canister any
day of the week
so
that's it that's all there was to this
beautiful
simple meal
that is so delicious i cannot wait to
get my mouth around it
it really didn't sound right
[Applause]
uh
ross
come try this
[Applause]
oh my gosh
okay i gotta ready
what
drew
that's amazing so
it's so simple
all about the parmesan
oh that's so delicious i really don't
feel like this needs any salt you're
gonna get the salt from inside the
cheese in the tortellini and you're
gonna get the salt from the parmesan
that's grated on there so
um here is my suggestion
for a simple affordable beautiful lovely
meal that works for everybody this
tastes like a million dollars thank you
drew oh thank you
[Applause]
by the way
i'm on a cleanse right now ross by the
way how's that going not great yeah
all right i hope you like this
restaurant
you know
i write a cookbook
say that again i wrote a cookbook you
did yeah it's called rebel homemaker oh
i'm so proud of you because i looked up
the definition of homemaker and i was
furious what did it say
it's so antiquated oh no well that's why
you're a rebel drew well i thought if i
put the word rebel in front of it we
might get somewhere
um so um that book is going to be out
and available and it has cost-effective
meals just like this i can't wait is
this one in it
no oh well we do
they don't need it you just show them
[Music]